Das ist aber selten, dass es Twitch innerhalb der ersten Minute checkt, dass der Stream
online ist.
Ja, wir haben auch nicht viel Zeit, eineinhalb Stunden, wir machen heute auch nichts großartiges.
Ein bisschen schwätzen, ein bisschen Video gucken oder sowas, keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß es noch nicht, genau, außer es gibt irgendwelche Special-Themen, über die ihr
sprechen wollt oder so.
Ach ja, übrigens eine coole Sache, kann ich euch jetzt zeigen, habe ich vorhin auf Heise
gelesen und zwar, und zwar, äh,
Sekunde, News-Sticker.
Wo ist es denn?
Home Office?
Bin ich jetzt bescheuert?
Wo ist der News-Post hin?
Oder war das bei Golem?
Bin mir gar nicht so sicher.
Das da!
Da bin ich dabei, da bin ich dabei.
Mir ist es eigentlich vollkommen egal, warum Home Office, aber hauptnere Home Office.
Und wisst ihr was noch viel besser ist?
Wisst ihr was noch viel besser ist an dieser Meldung?
Man kann jetzt sagen, also wenn jetzt irgendjemand sagt, wenn ich mal kurz das Ding hier weg,
wenn jetzt irgendjemand sagt, Home Office das ist nix, dann kannst du sagen, wer gegen
Home Office ist, ist für Putin und dann machen sie alle Home Office.
Also auf die Idee bin ich jetzt noch nicht gekommen, aber nach diesem Artikel, genau,
wer gegen Home Office ist, ist für Russland kann man jetzt sagen und dann ist Easy Home
Office für alle.
Easy, genau, um nicht zu sagen, bisschen laut, bisschen laut hier, warte mal, ich muss mal
kurz meinen Mixer ein bisschen, warte mal, nicht System Sounds, Soundtest, immer noch
zu laut, aber ist okay.
Richtig easy, genau, denke ich auch, ich brauch noch nen Kont, ja es ist echt so, jetzt weiß
ich was ich auf der Arbeit sagen kann, wenn ihr gegen Home Office seid, seid ihr für
Russland, seid ihr für Putin, easy, der Reuenlift ist am Start, geiler Name, Alter, Leute ich
war heute glaube ich so viel draußen wie die letzten 20 Jahre nicht mehr, ich war heute
bestimmt 5 Stunden am Stück im Freien, könnt ihr euch das vorstellen, es ist Massive MonkaS
Alter, dubsweb, danke für den Zapp, bist du braun geworden, nee, nicht wirklich, was
macht man so lange draußen, ich war zweimal, also ich war heute Morgen wandern und heute
Mittag war ich noch Eis essen draußen, aber jeweils immer ganzes Stück, ganze Stücke
laufen, dann hab ich die ganzen Kameras außen umpositioniert, also das sind die ganzen Kameras,
2 Stück, wieviel Schritte, Moment, ich hatte doch mal so ne Schrittzähler App, mal gucken
ob die gezählt hat, Sekunde, Schrittzähler, nope, ist das in der Health App drinnen, in
der Health App, ist das in der Health App drinnen, 10 Kilometer sagt er an der, er sagt
da hier, aber was ist das in Schritten, ja 14492 Steps, weil das mit Vorsicht zu genießen
ist, naja, zumindest ist das gar nicht so schlimm, glaubt man gar nicht, ja, Massive Pog, Discord,
ah nee, angeblich Serious Max, angeblich ist die Twitch-Meldung direkt raus gewesen
diesmal, naja, gut, Apple Watch haben wir ja gelernt, was Apple Watch alles tolles macht,
danke für den Sub, sorry, falls ich irgendjemanden übersehen hab, den hab ich nicht übersehen,
irgendjemanden hab ich übersehen, Doom's Web, danke für den Sub, Massive, ja, also
Apple Watch haben wir ja bei der Apple Präsentation gelernt, die Apple Watch hilft sogar schwangeren
Frauen zu erkennen, wenn sie ins Krankenhaus müssen, wenn das Kind kommt, ich dachte eigentlich
immer, bisher man merkt das, auch ohne Apple Watch, ich frag mich, wie haben die das beispielsweise
vor 200 Jahren gemacht, als die Apple Watch noch nicht da war, oder wie haben die das
noch bis 2015 gemacht überhaupt, daher müsste doch eigentlich permanent alles, alles schief
gegangen sein, ja, aber das haben wir bei der RNG, das haben wir bei der Apple Präsentation
gelernt, also Apple Watch sagt schwangeren Frauen Bescheid, wenn sie mal ins Krankenhaus
müssen, also Apple Watch sagt Achtung, Baby am Start, jazzi, danke für den Sub, haben
eure Firmen jetzt auch den Windows Defender für Handys eingeführt, noch nicht, sagt
es aber mal nicht so laut, weil sonst kommen die relativ schnell auf dumme Ideen, die,
wie gesagt, die kommen mal so schnell auf dumme Ideen, lul, omg, was sagst du zu Lost
Ark, was sage ich zu Lost Ark, das ist eine gute Frage, ich kann zu Lost Ark gar nicht
so viel sagen, weil ich Lost Ark nicht gespielt habe, also ich habe keine Ahnung davon, aber
das was ich gesehen habe in Streams und auf YouTube Videos sieht das Kampfsystem wirklich
äußerst wuchtig aus, also gut gemacht und die Sache ist halt die, dass wohl das Endgame
ein ultra mega Kreisel Grind ist, ein daily ultra mega Kreisel Grind, ja, warum nicht,
ich glaube wenn man 8 Stunden am Tag beschäftigt sein will ist das Game nicht schlecht, die
Playlist kann sich wieder mit der Lautstärke nicht entscheiden, ansonsten kann ich dazu
gar nichts sagen zu Lost Ark, ich glaube aber, eine Sache kann ich mit Sicherheit sagen,
Lost Ark Leute, ihr habt es zuerst gehört, Lost Ark ist wahrscheinlich besser als New
Ark, wo wir gerade beim Thema sind, wo wir gerade beim Thema sind und wenn ihr noch mehr
lachen wollt, die haben es letzte Woche geschafft, guckt euch das an, 832 Mann, ich mein ok,
jetzt ist Ostern, ja, jetzt ist es in Ordnung, das ist so mies, das ist so schlecht, ich fasse
es nicht, ich fasse es immer nicht, wenn ich das sehe, wie schlecht das eigentlich ist,
oh man, Spieler sind ein Legacy Feature, ja, richtig, von wegen, bald ist mein Stream größer
als die Player Base, mein letztes Video zur Battlefield hat mehr Likes als das Spiel auf
Steam aktive Spieler, muss man sich mal vorstellen, mehr Likes, tausend mehr, tausend Likes mehr
als aktive Spieler, null, ja, Janski, danke für den Zap, hab jetzt die, was, wie spricht
man die aus, Yi, YI, wer hat sich eigentlich bei den Amis ausgedacht, dass man Y ausspricht
oder so und W, das ist so unintuitiv, das ist der Grund warum die Leute AWP in CS AWP
aussprechen, ja, weil sie es nicht checken und weil man auch im Eifern des Gefechts nicht
dran denkt, AWP, das sagen im Zweifelsfall die Caster, weil die sich das über Jahre
antrainiert haben, ansonsten habe ich in Game immer AWP oder sowas gehört, AWP, die AWP,
das ist so ungeheuerlich, also ich hab jetzt meine Yi-Dome-Guard-Kamera mit dem Yi-Hack
von GitHub geflasht, ja, den habe ich auch im Einsatz, funktioniert auch ganz gut, hat
auch ziemlich die Funktion wie deine Kamera, aber günstiger, ja, aber das ist eine Dome-Kamera,
ich hab ja keine Dome-Kamera, ich hab hier eine, achso, die sieht, das ist übrigens
überhaupt keine Dome-Kamera, das ist Schwachsinn, eine Dome-Kamera ist normalerweise so ein
Ding, so ein flaches Ding, was du an die Decke hängst, sowas, normalerweise ist eine Dome-Kamera
sowas hier, jetzt machst du Huge-Paint-Skills, das hier ist die Decke, so Leute, das ist
die Decke, ne, und eine Dome-Kamera ist normalerweise, wie macht man eigentlich hier das größer,
size, eine Dome-Kamera ist normalerweise so ein Ding, und dann ist dann hier so die Kamera
drin und guckt raus, Huge-Paint-Skills, ja, aber die können das ja nennen, wie sie wollen,
wie lässt sich das flashen, wie gut lässt sich das flashen, wie macht man das, ich hab
übrigens nicht Je-Hacks, da Fang-Hacks hab ich auf GitHub, das da hab ich, ich hab mich
übrigens versprochen, das hab ich, nicht Je-Hacks, Squad, Squad-Steam, stimmt, das
ist ein Game, das find ich unglaublich nice, zum Zuschauen, aber selbst hab ich mich bisher
noch nie getraut, weil ich, weil das Spiel ist halt, soll ich sagen, wenn man sich 20
Minuten, also zumindest denk ich mir das, wenn man sich 20 Minuten anschleichen will
und halt so krasse Realismus-Infantry-Action machen will, ist das bestimmt nice, ich weiß
aber nicht, ob das das Richtige für mich ist, irgendwie, warum ist denn die Spielerzahlen
denn hier so hochgegangen, achso Corona wahrscheinlich, ja, aber Stable Player Base kann man echt
nix sagen, ich mein guck mal, die haben permanent zugelegt, jetzt ging's n bisschen runter,
aber das ist doch echt in Ordnung, ne, find ich gut, also das, das alles was ich von dem
gesehen hab, sind das tatsächlich mal Entwickler, die ein Game gemacht haben, wo ich den Eindruck
habe, das wollen sie selbst gerne spielen, ich hab selbst nicht gespielt, nur rein aus
Steams und Videos, die ich geguckt hab, das hat mehr Custom-Firmware, hast du die installiert,
ist das die Firmware, die du installiert hast auf deiner Kamera, ist das nicht das, wo
kein RTSP Server dabei ist, oder ist das nicht das, wo man den RTSP Server extra kaufen muss
oder so, ich hab mir nämlich auch mal ne andere Kamera gekauft und hab festgestellt,
die wollen damit Geld verdienen RTSP technisch und der funktioniert immer richtig, und der
ist dabei, oder wie, also den muss man auch nicht extra kaufen, probier ich mal aus, ich
glaube, ich muss mal kurz gucken, in meiner Amazon-History, ob ich nicht so ne Yi-Cam mal
gekauft habe, doch, ich hab eine Yi-Outdoor-Surveillance gekauft, geht das damit auch, was ist denn
supported, welche Kamera sind supported, supported devices, ne da ist wahrscheinlich
die nicht dabei, egal, wurscht, ich hab jetzt noch ne Reolink-Kamera gekauft, das ist zwar
auch billig China-Chinesen-Crap, aber es funktioniert ganz gut, schau mal weiter, nach welchem Fernseher
suchst du da im Tab, äh, gar nicht, achso, das ist, das ist den Fernseher, den ich schon
hab, den hab ich mir vor drei Jahren oder so gekauft, schaut mal bei dem anderen Repo,
was, Yi-Hack All-Star-2, warum benennt man denn seine, das da, warum benennt man denn,
das ist der Chip, oder, All-Winner, das ist der Chip, wo kann ich sagen, warum benennt
man das so, supported, ok, das muss ich mir mal angucken, vielleicht kann ich meine Kamera
noch recyceln, oh man, es ist langsam schon Bedgetime oder was, ähm, jo, danke für
den Zapp, Wub-Arrive, Wub-Abo-Falle, was machen wir heute, also, ich erzähl euch mal was,
was ich heute neben dem Wandern und draußen sein gemacht hab, ich hab ein bisschen angefangen
das Web-Interface für den Label-Champ zu programmieren, oder für den Print-Champ,
ich weiß noch nicht, wie ich das nennen soll, also für alle die dabei waren, mal so kurz
so als Recap, in einem der letzten Streams hab ich ja so einen Label-Drucker, also ich
hatte mir so einen Label-Drucker gekauft, da oben das Ding, und den haben wir das letzte
Mal eingerichtet, dass man von dem Raspberry Pi aus damit drucken kann, ein paar USB,
und jetzt brauch ich noch ein Web-Interface, wo ich mir simpel ein paar Labels zusammen
klicken kann, da basteln wir selbst was, ich wollt ja ursprünglich Draw-IO, also das da,
embedden, dass man damit seine Labels malen kann, geht deiner noch ohne DRM-Paper, ja,
das funktioniert, ich hab jetzt, wo ist denn das Problem jetzt, konnte man das nicht, mit
der Seite, stimmt doch was, man konnte das doch, ah nee hier, das wollte ich jetzt sagen,
ich hab Third-Party-Papier drinnen, das funktioniert, ok, Moment, ich mach das mal auf, Labello,
das Ding ist Magic, ja, das ist schön, ich hab aber den nicht, ich brauch, wobei vielleicht
schick ich den Krempel zurück, und was ist das, hat das ein Web-Interface, ok, ok, ok,
geht das, geht das für Dymo, also hat das ein Label Designer, Web-Interface dabei, also
ich mein, solange ich per Kommandozeile das umwursten kann, das ist so ein typisches Projekt,
wo wirklich sehr von einem Screenshot des Web-Interfaces, ich buck mal, von einem Screenshot
des Web-Interfaces irgendwie profitieren würde, nee nee nee, Dymo Connect Framework bringt
gar nichts, Leute, das muss ich jetzt an der Stelle noch einmal loswerden, ich muss jetzt
mal merken, wo wir hier, ich seh das total oft, die Leute gehen auf Google und posten
mir den erstbesten Link in Chat, als hätt ich nicht schon danach gegoogelt, das hier
bringt mir überhaupt nichts, das hier bringt dir, das ist ein kleinen Framework, also sprich,
wenn du deinen Rechner schon mit Dymo Treiber eingerichtet hast, dann kannst du mit diesem
Framework auf den schon eingerichteten und schon vorhandenen Dymo Drucker mit dem passenden
Treiber für das Betriebssystem deiner Wahl zugreifen, im Prinzip ist das quasi eine
Fernsteuerung für den Printdialog mit ein bisschen, mit ein bisschen Spezialdinger dabei,
ich hab mir das schon alles angeguckt, also es gibt ein paar Sachen in dieser Richtung,
aber nichts, was mir gefällt, deswegen, wir machen ein eigenes Webinterface, da kann ich
bei der Gelegenheit auch mal probieren, ein bisschen Grafik-Editor Zeug zu machen, das
wird was ganz Simples, man kann QR Codes einfügen, Bar Codes einfügen, Schrift einfügen und
Bilder reincopy pasten, fertig aus, Conva JS, ne, genau, wahrscheinlich machen wir das
damit, guck mal, das ist ganz praktisch, Demos, da kann man eigene Design-Label-Editor-Dinger
bauen, relativ einfach, wobei, das ist viel zu sophisticated das Beispiel, das ist nicht
einfach.
Sagen wir mal, die haben doch gescheite Demos sonst immer gehabt, keine Ahnung, ich hab
vorher ein bisschen geguckt, Basic Demo, genau, da kannst du so Dinger hier machen, guck,
da kannst du relativ easy so eigene, wie nennt man das, Editor-Dinger zusammenwursten damit,
das hat Rotate standardmäßig drin, Resize und so standardmäßig drin, unclickbar und
Groupen und so mit drin, da musst du gar nicht viel machen, da hab ich vorhin auch schon
ein bisschen mit rumgespielt, das ist tatsächlich ziemlich, ziemlich easy, damit was zu bauen
und wir machen einfach nen ganz simplen Editor, wo man Text reinschreiben kann, Labello, gibt
es irgendeinen Screenshot von der Geschichte, in das Webinterface ausschauen, Labello ist
das nicht so Lippen, Lippenstift, ne ne, da musst du nicht ins Dorf fahren jetzt, bei
der Gelegenheit kann ich mich ein bisschen mit Javascript Grafik zeichnen Kram mal auseinandersetzen,
wie so verkehrt, Titan Toast, danke für den Tier 1 Sub oder was heißt Titan Toast, Windows
Defender für Linux, ja Moment, es heißt ja nicht Windows Defender für Linux, es heißt
Microsoft Advanced Threat Protection, das, so heißt das, Advanced Threat Protection,
das klingt besser als Windows Defender für Linux, ich hab's gekauft, mehr hab ich noch
nicht gemacht, es gibt so viele Sachen aktuell, die ich machen muss oder spielen muss oder
was auch immer, ich komm bei den angesagten Games teilweise erst das halbes Jahr später
zu spielen oder so, da ist der Hype schon wieder vorbei, wisst ihr so in 2 Jahren sag
ich dann so meine Meinung zu Elgin Ring, wenn es keine Sau mehr interessiert, spielst du
noch Lost Ark, also mit Daily Cryant, was hältst du vom Twitter Takeover, ja da bin
ich mal gespannt, ich mein Elon Musk ist ja eh schon so quasi wie soll man sagen, nicht
wirklich Shitposter, aber wie nennt man sowas, keine Ahnung, er ist ja schon relativ aktiv
auf Twitter, was ja mittlerweile dazu führt, dass wenn der was tweetet, erstmal irgendwelche
Kryptowährungen um 50% steigen oder so, das ist teilweise richtig krass und ich wette
mit euch, ich hab nicht nachgeguckt, aber ich wette mit euch, es gibt Bots, die checken
was Elon Musk twittert und wenn es dort irgendwelche Namen von börsennotierten Unternehmen drin
findet, dann wird das automatisch gekauft, übrigens erinnert ihr euch noch an dieses
Video, Fisch Stonks YouTube, dieses Video wo die, das da, warum findet der das, ich
suche nach Fisch Stonks YouTube und er findet das Video was ich meine, wir haben noch dieses
Video geguckt mit dem Fisch der Aktienkauf, was eigentlich ziemlich clickbait im Titel
war und ich hab mir was überlegt, ich hab mir überlegt, man könnte, man könnte was
ähnliches bauen und zwar, und zwar Chico Beiss Aktien, ich könnte meine Katze Aktien
kaufen lassen und ich hab mir auch schon überlegt, ich hab mir auch schon überlegt wie man das
machen könnte und zwar, ich hab ein Katzenklo unten im Erdgeschoss und ich hab ein Katzenklo
oben und bei beiden Katzenklos steht irgendwo in der Nähe ne Kamera, dass ich mit bekomme
jetzt schon theoretisch wenn die Katz aufs Klo geht, ich meine ich guck nicht explizit
ob die Katz aufs Klo geht, aber im Kamerawinkel ist jeweils das Katzenklo drinne und dann
könnte ich quasi anhand des Klos auf das Chico geht entscheiden welche Stonks gekauft
werden 1.000.000 Views incoming, was das, ja haben wir doch grad geguckt, Stylors danke
für den Sub, ne nicht Stylors, Stelsor, Stelsor, Stelsor, meine Güte ich kann ihn mal lesen
da, APP, wie weit bin ich eigentlich hinten dran, wann installierst du die Windows 11 nach
Windows 12, also wenn ich die Chance hab Windows 10 auszusetzen bis Windows 12 kommt und das
mich mehr anspricht dann sitze ich Windows 11 aus, The Groove Electric, Dankeschön
für den Sub, ok
das
und die wurden jetzt aufgekauft von Nestle oder sowas genau und da wird jetzt da wird jetzt wild
rum geflamed über der teuerter Scheiß wo jetzt von Nestle aufgekauft wurde ich habe keine Ahnung
ob das so ist aber generell kaufen die sowas ja bestimmt nicht auf wenn es grad mal so irgendwie
erfolgreich ist die kaufen da was auf was sie entweder in zukunft anteile abnehmen könnte
oder was wo sie sich was für die zukunft versprechen ich bin eher mal gespannt ob
Elon Musk Twitter kauft oder was da jetzt rauskommt am ende
naja so was können wir uns mal anschauen erst mal kurz gucken was haben wir hier offen
also hallo in diesem stream nur ganz kurz max wann kaufst du reddit ich hätte gerne die
Kohle um reddit zu kaufen und dann würde ich folgendes machen auf reddit leute
ich was würde ich machen was würde ich machen wenn ich reddit kaufe okay ich
weiß was ich machen würde wenn ich reddit kaufe ich würde das neue reddit design gleich mal
wegkicken richtig genau das und ich würde eine gescheite reddit app programmieren lassen und
ich würde diese komischen reddit live streams wahrscheinlich abschaffen wo ich bis heute nicht
verstanden habe warum es überhaupt reddit video live streaming gibt also die die
daseinsberechtigung erschließt sich mir überhaupt nicht ich sehe da meistens irgendwelche also wenn
ich reddit aufmache und die sind richtig weird jam gestern war ich auf reddit und da habe ich
den den dieses dings was sie da immer in der empfohlene stream oder so was dazwischen da
in post steht ja entweder entweder sind es leute die musikinstrumente spielen aber ich
hatte letztens ein live stream von irgend so ein paar hühnern auf auf der wiese oder oder im
näher wiese war das nicht im gehege hühner der hat seine hühner gefilmt die darum gekocht ja
der hat seine hühner gefilmt die darum gelaufen sind warum warum genau ist das recommended high
IQ stream jetzt gerade auf reddit ja das wäre bei mir wieder die fall wobei ich es nicht so
lassen würde ich würde da schon modernisieren aber nicht so abartig wie es jetzt ist und eine
sache würde ich auf reddit abschaffen ja nicht ob nicht wall street jetzt die würde ich nicht
abschaffen aber ich will mal was zeigen und zwar so das ist das neue reddit design und die haben
was was mich mega aufregt nämlich diese endless crawl geschichte das erste was ich abschaffen
würde ist das erste was ich machen würde ist ich würde endless crawl abschaffen und ein etwas
besseres navigationsmenü bauen als das da irgendwas was die letzten 50 seiten anzeigt und dann halt
xxx oder sowas hier weiß es ja nicht genau ach ja und die suche würde ich auch nach möglichkeit
irgendwie verbessern wobei besuche ganz ehrlich die github suche ich weiß nicht warum die immer noch
da ist die github suche ist so random useless teilweise das blick ich auch nicht auch guck mal
was trendet denn heute china chinesen zeug n lp china language processing oder so
der ding dong help der ding dong helfer ist am start alles klar der ding dong helfer aber auch
china chinesen zeug sache mal trendet heute noch was anderes außer china chinesen zeug
irgendwie auf wobei ich weiß ja nicht ob das chinesisch 5.000 sterne ich weiß nicht mal was
es sein soll gut ich kann auch kein chinesisch hat zwei facebook grämpel
blockchain dark forest self guard handbook also der name schreckt mich schon mal ab
wie dankeschön für den sub das kenne ich das den kenne ich das ist ein ein köl ersatz das ist
wirklich gut das ding das finde ich nice system design primer interview question her die um
her die wenn fertig was der weiter erkennst du du erkennst anhand der überschrift immer was es
sein soll 69 stars alda was soll das sein hartfork of franz und und wer ist franz
ein metamessenger sozusagen ok man sieht es macht es richtig painstab aber jetzt
übrigens ich habe heute ein richtig cooles projekt entdeckt das kennt ihr wahrscheinlich
alle schon aber ich zeige es euch trotzdem mal alter mein gott github mensch du musst
github am besten über google durchsuchen besser dass da das ist richtig nice das ist
ein kommando zeilen tool mit dem du hintergründe von bildern entfernen kannst guck so zu so mit
transparenz sowas gibt es als web service schon an vielen stellen aber ich finde cool dass das
als kommando zeilen tool gibt und mich wundert es nicht manchmal also das hat schon ein paar
kleine fehler aber im groß und ganz ist das eigentlich ziemlich gut guckt euch das mal
also das kann er schlecht hier abschneiden aber das ist das ist an sich ziemlich gut
lass mal testen mit was mit was willst du testen ausschneidet schimpf naja zumindest finde ich
das sehr nice weil davor vor meinem klo mit schicko wollen wir das mal ausprobieren mit
schicko also mit dem bild ist das einzige was von schicko da hab mal schicko testen ob
er den hintergrund ausschneiden kann ok testen wir jetzt und dann testen wir das mit einem
youtube bild aus dem youtube video von meinem klo ich mache mal kurz rest auf das kart genau
genau es gibt sowas schon zum beispiel da ja das ist richtig es gibt sich ganz viele
dieser services aber ich finde cool dass es ein fix und fertiges programm gibt pipp install
rem bg breser rief eigentlich heute nix großartiges was ist denn bing image of the day aha das
ist bing image of the day was sehe ich denn da ist das frankreich arch by the way ja ich
wollte jetzt sagen ist das der triumfbogen keine ahnung so rem bg rem bg vielleicht
gibt es im package nein gibt es nicht pipp install wie ging das mal mit local install
pipp rem bg ok mein terminal muss dahin da muss der browser hin testen wir doch mal
testen wir mal ob das funktioniert so bei der gelegenheit müssen wir gerade mal kurz
das bild von schicko auf die vm übertragen sonst funktioniert das nämlich nicht so rem
bg github rem bg schauen wir mal was wir lassen uns mal im vorfeld schauen was würden wir
denn erwarten was rauskommt bei dem bild was ist hier hintergrund das ist gar nicht so
einfach zu beantworten also das einzige was mir einfällt ist halt die wand die wand ist
halt die frage was man freistellen will die katze ist die decke dabei ich bin mal gespannt
ich bin mal gespannt was der daraus macht das pisen zeug geht aber ab installation technisch
was ist der mit meinem top los was habe ich da eingestellt sort bei cpu ja geht doch
aus wird compiled leute tensor flow shit ach nee nun bei ok auch gut nein was ist jetzt
oh fuck schnup ich habe abgebrochen keck weight was ist monka es alter wie lange ist diese
fehler meldung man ok dependencies vielleicht sollte ich die pendencies checken dependencies
diese fehler meist vollkommen egal meinst du ich meine der konnte eindeutig nun nun
peinlich installieren aus gründen die sich mir nicht so ganz erschließen wenn ich ehrlich
bin aber ok ich meine was soll das hier schon wieder sein da blickt doch keiner durch pipp
ist pence jam ja das stimmt ok ist er jetzt fertig dann bg tatsächlich ok wie führt man
das jetzt aus rem bg remove background was remove background vom lokal feier remove background
vom arlen ok remove lokal feier und dann haben jetzt cico jpg macht das jetzt was was habe
ich denn bei meinem hardtop eingestellt dass das so broken ist also ganz ehrlich so so
gut so nice peisen ist aber der paket manager kram ist einfach absoluter crap ich habe damit
so viel probleme schon gehabt und wenn er mit plot als library abhängigkeit hat warum
ist es nicht einfach mit installiert worden wo ist der sinn warum ist es nicht mit installiert
worden und warum steht stehen da keine dependencies gibt es nicht als docker container oder sowas
what the fuck muss ich updaten jetzt noch oder was ok jetzt muss ich erst mal ein betriebssystem
updaten seriously na gut warten wirs mal ab schauen wir mal was rauskommt gleich wenn
es das wäre kein problem wenn das funktionieren würde dass das funktioniert siehst du an
ganz vielen art user repo packages die werden ja auch gebildet mit custom scripts und sowas
rum und das funktioniert und ich habe auch ganz viele rubikrempel früher benutzt und
die haben auch ganz gerne marce extensions gab die es hat auch funktioniert oder sogar
fucking npm und node js funktioniert meistens ich habe den output vergessen ok hast du
schon wird schon nf benutzen ich benutze das 3 10er peißen was installiert ich meine
es muss ja so funktionieren usage s docker gibt es das als docker ja dann ist easy zeigt
mal her ach hier first compile with ok also müssen wir uns den krempel klonen oder wie
alles klar klop klonchamp repos git klon rem bg so und was jetzt docker bild docker bild
jawohl gib ihm nvidia kuda das wird aber nix bei mir in der vm jetzt ich mein vielleicht
es ist einfach nur optional opera moment kann mir irgendjemand erklären warum ich opera
installiert habe hier china chinesen zeug man hello again das muss ich gleich mal löschen
was bei festplatte ist gleich voll wenn das so weiter geht die chinesen sind schon auf
der vm eingelog kein problem sei froh dass es kein npm shells ist naja npm funktioniert
meistens es lädt halt das halbe internet nach npm ist halt so dass das java script
ökosystem ist halt wir du installierst irgendeine kommando zeilen ab und hast erst
mal 80000 dependencies und das ist doch nicht mal übertrieben was das liegt am köln update
das liegt das liegt am köln update reboot gleich haben wir es gleich haben wir es easy
install das muss man halt sagen also da kann mir keiner erzählen dass es krasse usability
oder so das ist jetzt nicht wirklich die schuld von linux und die distributionen nicht so
wirklich aber das ist schon das ist so ein ding das hast du öfters mal aus der linux
so so wie red dinger ja ok bild tipp haben wir es jetzt geschafft oder was ok rmbg minus
achte habe ich vergessen keck weh punkt jpeg warum alles ja warum hat er das nicht einfach
mit installieren und warum braucht der matt merck plot oder so dafür habe ich es jetzt
richtig gemacht vom parameter von den parametern her
so das schreibt er doch so dass das so funktioniert muss ich so machen vielleicht
ja wie benutze ich das denn jetzt
die liegt hier laut usage gibt es kein i aber in der read me auf der im repo steht das drinnen
dass man ein i machen soll also wenn schede mal das stimmt
ist das überhaupt das richtige programm was wir hier installiert haben
ohne i hat das ding irgendwie eine ausgabe dass ich sehen kann was das ist
ok wo sind wir denn
ja nice da weiß man bescheid ja das wird schon das wird schon das richtige sein
also mal ganz im ernst was ist das da wieder mit schwachsinn
rmbgs man kann das auch als server laufen lassen ok
sagen wir haben wir haben nicht das richtige programm installiert oder
ich meine haben wir eigentlich
aber vielleicht doch nicht egal das funktioniert der andere krempel auch nicht
was examples
nee es geht aber nicht mal das als server starten
ok ich habe absolut kein platzen schimmer wir probieren es jetzt mal im docker container
warum gibt es denn auch nicht mal aminus help version vielleicht oder sowas
man muss man muss man muss direkt und dann minus o machen
nicht input muss so machen und dann minus o ja aber warum ist das warum ist die
ritme so so verkackt an pickling er war
alter was ein schwachsinn mann so ok docker dann da gucken wir uns jetzt an
usage usage in docker container
so docker run i
haben wir mal home wir machen das ergeben das mal absolut an max checker jpeg
in der zeit hätte ich das wahrscheinlich in dem x beliebigen tool ausschneiden können
ja und funst es jetzt was habe ich was habe ich denn mit meinem hardtop gemacht
eigentlich dass es so kaputt ist
muss es im gleichen verzeichnis liegen
oder muss das wirklichen png sein aber davon abgesehen
und auf heil der rektor ist egal
ja nice
ja wahrscheinlich warum ist also was ich meine jetzt mal ernsthaft hier ist es ein
minus i als parameter
hier ist es ein ein normales i als parameter oder ist das mit minus i vom docker
also
so wie macht man pipp remove gibt es remove kann man kann man pipp sachen
remove so uninstall oder sowas uninstall jambig yes
weg damit den restlichen kram entfernt er nicht oder was
ok so wie macht man jetzt ein virtual entf das ist das mache ich so gut wie nie
welches denn das das oder das
ach genau das ist jetzt eingebaut so war das da
und da muss man irgendwie source activate machen ich erinnere mich mk dir keq test
alles klar so und jetzt muss man irgendwie sagen sagen sauce bin activate wenn ich das
noch richtig in erinnerung habe so jetzt 0w pipp install rambi g
oh guckt mal hier sogar mit krasser grafischer anzeige
das ist ja mal richtig advanceder shit hier guckt euch das an
jetzt aber richtig pfeif hätt ich alles
installing collected packages file type command werkzeug
bin installiert ok bin rem bg
moment es war für den server ok das scheint schon mal zu funktionieren
netz das nö da lauscht nix
ok jetzt kopiere ich mal das was in der read mit drin steht
ich kopier mir sogar ich kopier mir sogar das bild hierhin
mein png meinetwegen was will ja ok pipp install ich mein warum ist es
denn nicht als dependency drinne was ist das für den rotz gibt es jetzt
eigentlich mittlerweile minus minus version oder sowas ok ok wir gucken mal nicht dass
ich die falsche python version habe oder sowas
nee habe ich nicht vnv nee wie guckt man das nach was man für
einen default python interpreter hat mit wobei ich habe ja vnv python 3 gemacht da kann
ja eigentlich nix passieren mit 3.10 ist es kaputt ernsthaft steht es
bei den issues irgendwo
ok nee nee das ist
ok nee pipp muss doch muss doch python 3 sein oder
ja ja das ist egal
so wie installiert man in einem virtualenv eine neue python version gibt es irgendwie
python version manager oder sowas pnv also ich kenne rbn von ruby noch wie macht man
das
nee nee pipp ist hier dreier standardmäßig ok wie installiert man sich jetzt da gibt
es
oder kann oder kann vnv auch die version ändern oder was
geht das hier virtualenv the fuck nee das war was anderes
leute was nimmt man da wenn ich unterschiedliche python version installieren will ich weiß
wir können es auch einfach mit dem docker container machen das ist wahrscheinlich wirklich
sinnvoller jetzt jetzt artet das hier wieder aus das hatte ich eigentlich überhaupt nicht
vor
so das hat er nicht funktioniert weil es nicht findet
um so
auf wie maunt ich den krempel jetzt muss ich da
vorwiegend das ist minus das war ich aus minus faune ja minus faun und man muss absolute
fahne angeben das da kann ich mich auch dran erinnern max
ja ich weiß doch gar nicht wohin ich das mounten muss wo der container nachguckt das
ist doch mal maximal hängen geblieben sollte ich jetzt in den stocker fall reingucken was
startet oder was wo in welchem verzeichnis überhaupt hier slash rem bg oder
man kann ja keine einzelnen falls falls muss jetzt ein extra verzeichnis für die katz machen
oder was so ok minus faun haum man geht eigentlich
keine autocomplete haum max repos rem bg katz nach dahin oder keine ahnung ob das funktioniert
alter wobei ich könnte ich könnte auch dahin maunten und jetzt sage ich katze slash das
funktioniert auch so nett das muss da muss ich jetzt slash katze so und
jetzt habe ich mit meinem hardtop gemacht oh er installiert dinger leute das ist schon
mal ahja weil kein kuda drauf ist ja ich will das doch auch nicht mit kuda machen man keck
w tool man ok kannst du schach programmieren also spielen kann ich nicht programmieren
könnte ich wahrscheinlich wenn ich mir die regeln durchlese aber das glaube ich nicht
dass ich das in nächster zeit machen würde das ist nichts was man jetzt einfach mal so
nebenbei macht du heiratest mich dann ist wahrscheinlich eher ein grund das nicht zu
machen oder so wie installiert man denn jetzt ordentlich ein ok pie enf wie installiert
man das hat man wir machen das über den package manager pie enf pie enf ok excellent pie enf
install was brauchen wir 3.9 oder 3.9.11 excellent ok
3.9 ist raus naja es ist 3.10 ja schon raus ok schach ist aber cool nicht so
wie du ultra harter dis hier wieder gerade oder ist ganz schön beschäftigt kann man
den plan gibt es so was wie eine h top rc oder sowas irgendwas habe ich da umgestellt
und ich weiß nicht was konfig h top konfig h top h top rc weckte mit ich will die fault
ne ah doch irgendwie ist trotzdem ein bisschen broken keine ahnung ok hart installiert so
jetzt pie enf activate oder irgendwie sowas wahrscheinlich pie enf global 3.9 3.9.11 ok
pierson minus minus version muss ich jetzt noch mal neu starten da muss ich doch bestimmt
noch irgendwas in meine bash rc oder sowas ein eintragen dass das funktioniert was habe
ich bestimmt noch nicht gemacht pie enf shell was muss man da machen bash rc da muss man
doch garantiert bash rc oder zsh was mac os monka es man das da ne ne das geht nicht
sowas diesen ganzen müll muss ich da reinschreiben jetzt oder was ist aber krasser moment ist
doch alles das doppelte ist das zweimal das gleiche äh das zweimal das gleiche sag mal
sind heute alle readmys abfuck schlecht oder bin ich zu dumm da gibt es nichts zu lesen
das ende ist anders pie enf init pass ach hier profile ach so ja aber das kann man doch
nicht erwarten dass man das sieht ja ok wunderbar moment das ist auch schwachsinn das kommt
da gar nicht rein was mache ich denn hier das ist auch gar nicht für die das ist gedacht
das ist auch gar nicht so gedacht das ist gedacht das hier rein zu kopieren also im
endeffekt so aber aber warum so umständlich man so soll das sein ok pie enf global
ha ha das ist schon mal besser ok ok keck wie test null wie das ist das schmeißer wieder
weg fau enf so und jetzt installieren was neu so und wir haben jetzt auch ich kann aber
schreiben wir haben jetzt auch 3.9 die letzte version 3.9 activate so ok install und wenn
es jetzt nicht geht dann gibt es da heute nichts mit dem tool alter was soll das sein
ist etwas mit euch los heute
so ist es jetzt fertig hat es jetzt funktioniert kenni der selected for donut also erjängt
version ich hinter ich hinterfragt das jetzt schon mal gar nicht bg so moment moment risch
ja doch das ist auch falsch moment e cp moment die katze dahin kopieren und jetzt ach ne
medplot fehlt ja immer noch tangle danke für den sub warum hat das ding eigentlich
wenn du pipp installierst warum fehlt dem noch was ist es nicht normal dass man seine
dependencies da eigentlich mit auflistet dass der kram moment moment geht es jetzt ohne
medplot es hat funktioniert keck weit haben wir ein chrome direkt auf chromium out durchaus
ganz ok mit der decke hatte er offensichtlich probleme das ist aber auch ein äußerst ungünstiges
foto muss man sagen wir probieren jetzt was anderes wir machen jetzt ein foto von einem
klo wir können es mal testen in remove bg es gibt ja dann auch mehr remove bg upload
image passt mal auf wir verwenden wir verwenden mal einen von diesen von diesen services
guck die kriegen das besser hin hier ist es hier ist es richtig gut die hams die hams
direkt hinbekommen also da gibt es fertige services die das die das machen die sind relativ
gut vielleicht vielleicht muss man dem aber auch noch kann mir irgendjemand mal erklären
was zum teufel ich vorhin installiert habe wo es kein minus i gab und so das war doch
ein komplett anderes tool was ich vorhin installiert habe hier guck mal bg 20 was ist denn da das
richtige 2011 tatsächlich was entwickler hat vergessen und was hat entwickler vergessen
welche pakete entzählen ja das kann sein ja ausführen please
jetzt gibt es noch nicht mal mehr minus ha ok ich habe keine ahnung
jetzt hat es funktioniert warum geht es denn jetzt auf einmal ach so weil ich die globale
python version gesetzt habe weil weil ich gesagt habe glaube ah ja ja ja ja alles klar
wie hast du den total commander in die schnellstaatleiste umbekommen ich habe weder ein total commander
noch irgendwas dergleichen in meiner schnellstaatleiste was was meinst du was ist da
total commander das da das ist einfach nur ein icon das ist ein emoji mit der diskette
das ist ein diskette emoji das hat nix mit dem total commander zu tun ok jetzt jetzt
reicht es mir wirklich großartige argument angeben kann man da nicht was ich aber list
vielleicht wie lässt man sich jetzt anzeigen was für python version man hat versions also
ich habe system glaube system so und jetzt habe ich wieder python version 3.0 und wenn
ich es jetzt installiere dann kackts wieder ab ne ja jetzt macht er wieder komische komische
dinge ach guck mal jetzt hat er rmbg 1027 installiert was ist denn das für ein ultra pains champ
hoch 10 man 1027 das das das das das gibt es hier noch nicht mal hex 1027 das ist das
ist das ist älter als die älteste version das verstehe ich nicht also ganz ehrlich das
ist den teil an passen wahrscheinlich nie verstehen werde wie man ordentlich pipp handelt
ich mein kann das ding nicht einfach sagen also ich mein anstatt eine version zu installieren
von vor 50 jahren einfach geht nicht oder irgendwas was auch was auch immer aber man
kann ja auch nichts dran drehen ans settings naja gut was was auch immer wir haben es wir
haben es geschafft opera noch installieren er ja richtig weg damit also wieder zumachen
war es minus minus remove opera ich weiß es kacke ne minus er minus er war das opera und
dann so dass der auch alle abhängigkeiten installiert genau da wunderbar so opera warum
habe ich opera dabei was ist das hier wir wollten ein pausen tool installieren was hintergründe
entfernt und das hat auch so halbwegs so halbwegs funktioniert es hat auch so halbwegs funktioniert
er hat er hat ein bisschen probleme mit der decke auf die meiner katze drauf liegt da
kommt er nicht ganz klar aber der rest hat erstaunlich gut funktioniert aber online services
sind in dem fall tatsächlich immer noch besser weil der hat es sofort ohne probleme gemacht
gut waren wir davor nee ja kannst du je nach betriebssystem du kannst es als package machen
also als depp oder als p.m. oder als target setter oder slackware oder als arch user repo
oder als was haben wir sonst noch leute mir fallen gerade gar nicht mehr wir fallen gar
nicht mehr so viele paket paket formate ein depp abt slack hat einfach nur target setz
glaube ich das ist total easy oder besser gesagt pains champ ich pack man ja gut app
image ja snap alda ein msi und exe zählt nicht flat pack stimmt das haben wir auch
noch aber ich meine jetzt von unterschiedlichen distros eigentlich ah dieses l pine zeugs
haben wir noch alpine apk genau dmg smag ja aber so wirklich so wirklich sind doch außer
debian also außer depp und p.m. sind doch so im großen stil gar nicht mehr viel anderes
übrig geblieben oder fällt mir jetzt nix ein du hast entweder irgendwas debian basiertes
also sei es debian ubuntu mint was nicht alles gibt oder du hast irgendwas p.m. basiertes
oder du hast halt das beste wenn man nämlich arch by the way verwendet weil arch nur die
high IQ leute verwenden arch ich benutze ich benutze übrigens auch arch by the way wo wir
gerade dabei sind ach gentu emerge ja die war das emerge unter gentu ach tatsächlich
ja das ist eine gute idea kann man mal gucken super ja opensuse alter opensuse ist auch so
ein ding da mache ich einen großen bogen drum pkg denn das gibt es ja nicht mehr oder
gibt es noch irgendwelche überlebenden abkömmlinge von mandriva das war es eigentlich viel mehr
slackware slackware slackware sind doch eigentlich dachte ich immer direkt hgz gewesen vielleicht
ist es das im endeffekt auch was ich was für ein ding ich ich das kann ich aber aussprechen
ich bin ganz verwirrt heute kannst du vergessen
alles klar leute jetzt wissen wir bescheid hat deutlich länger gedauert als ich mir das
vorgestellt habe wir gucken uns jetzt noch was an das video wurde mir empfohlen freund
auf youtube coding in c until my program ist unsafe das dauert noch 47 sekunden also ich
tippe mal drauf dass der irgendwie so was macht wie keine ahnung print f ist es gleich
an self oder irgendwie sowas das ist wahrscheinlich reicht wahrscheinlich reicht schon der erste
import oder das erste include dass es an self ist oder irgendwie sowas
ok das ist würde ich sagen noch safe
da wird wahrscheinlich ist hiernach schon vorbei wahrscheinlich ist jetzt shut down
wahrscheinlich jetzt jetzt ist schon shut down ok so now we need to get input from the
user from arkby it's gonna be three characters we need to create three room for it so care
oh na das ist ja schon mal unsafe per landung wenn ich das wort sehe ist das schon anseif
war klar dass sowas in der richtung kommt jetzt kennst du das video mit dem senior java script
developper ja das fand ich tatsächlich ganz gut und lustig die anderen videos von dem
sind irgendwie so weiß nicht weirtschäpp
die du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du
du du wir haben noch 10 minuten zeit die besten 10 windows productivity apps in 2022 leute jetzt
machen wir machen es tritt 17 wir gucken das video nicht sondern wir schauen in die beschreibung
und hoffen der hat ein liste mit den programmen drinnen ok share x nicht zu verwechseln mit
x share
Ähnlich Aber was Komplett Anderes
Quick look das Kenne Ich Nicht was ist quick look
Also Ich würde Mal Vermuten IrGendwie eine Vorschau Für. Dateien oder so Zeit Meier
ApNumber 2 on this little called quick look and if you've ever used Mac OS you probably know there is a function
Built into the operating system
Which is Sadly Absent on Windows
Well, ja gut im Windows Explorer ist so ziemlich alles absent was man Brings it in there
Now in Mac OS quick look is a function in finder where you can
Basically click on a file without opening it and see information about that file in the sidebar you can see an image
Da das ist plot so was gibt es unter mir noch nicht text inside of a text file and the quick look app instead of the microsoft
Windows store adds this to windows you can click on a file
Opening it you can just hit the spacebar to preview it now. This is less useful for okay das problem
Nächste ist notion das ist in den editor oder
das ist das ist irgendein
Macdown editor oder so nicht brauche ich nicht edge
Ernsthaft
Da ist jetzt will jetzt will er uns doch auf den armen nehmen oder
Next Clipboard Manager. Warum nicht den
Nicht den in Windows eingebauten verwenden
Er verwendet den eingebauten
Ja genau
Das ist tatsächlich sinnvoll ja das stimmt
Ich habe schon öfters es gibt ja tausende programme in dieser richtung weiß nicht ich habe nie wirklich
Die daseinsberechtigung davon gecheckt und ich bin damit auch nie warm geworden
Es panne so schon wieder so ein ding
Was das auch so was in der richtung expand ach nee das ist irgendwelche
Nicht macros sondern text schnipsel oder sowas ja ok
Das ist eine suche die ist tatsächlich ganz ok aber das ist auch schon das ist auch schon jahre alt das google drive alter
Ok das ist wirklich cool
Das ist tatsächlich ich glaube das einzige programme in der liste wo ich sag das ist wirklich so ja doch share x habe ich auch
Und everything ist tatsächlich auch ganz cool aber f looks ist wirklich nice
Da kannst du deinen bildschirm dunkler machen ab
Eingestellte uhrzeit oder was heißt dunkler nicht nur dunkler sondern auch
Weniger blau töne und sowas das ist das ist cool nee ich glaube windows kann das mittlerweile nicht nicht so gut
Das verdunkel beziehungsweise färben des bildschirms bringt nichts warum bringt das nichts das ist doch
Ein deutsch geschmackssache oder
Das ist wissenschaftlich erwiesen
Also unabhängig davon ob das wissenschaftlich erwiesen ist oder nicht ich finde zum einschlafen gelbtöne
beziehungsweise nicht mehr so kellen bildschirm
angenehmer
Also ob das jetzt wissenschaftlich erwiesen ist oder nicht ich finde es tatsächlich angenehmer
Also deswegen ist immer die frage was ist denn eigentlich genau wissenschaftlich erwiesen und fast nicht
Ok das war wirklich nice
Jetzt haben wir uns als nächstes angucken was das denn ica
Was zum wind ring kling kling wind wind ok moment
Pro
Nounciation und man das ist das ist schwedisch oder
swedisch
Windrichtung
Was
Windrichtung moment moment was
Wien windrigning ok windrigning
Ach du scheiße man kann man das können die das hier aussprechen hier schwedisch
Das ist ja noch schlimmer
Windrichtung windrichtung
Windrichtung windrichtung alles klar ok also ica windrigning
Den habe ich mir bestellt bei ica
und
Das gucken wir jetzt nicht das werde ich nachbauen vielleicht war man das auch im stream zusammen
Damit kann man sich nämlich einen
Luftqualitäts sensor selbst bauen der günstiger ist als ver als quasi
Also das ist gerät mit sensor was günstiger ist als sensor alleine kaufen also ica hat manchmal ganz coole sachen
windrigning
Das ist nicht der luftreinige das der luftqualitäts
Sensor da kann man ich kann es ich kann es ja in dem video mal zeigen da kann man
Seinen eigenen controller dran löten schau mal
hier
Das ist das sind die kontakte von dem sensor die in diesem windrigning drin sind
Und ica war nett und hat die kontakte sogar groß gemacht und gelabelt
Und war so nett und hat kraut und fünf volt auch rausgeführt
also fast als will ica
Dass man den kram selber benutzt mit irgendwelchem eigenen microcontroller camp
Das bauen wir dann also ich habe das bestellt vielleicht kommt es am samstag also morgen wenn es morgen kommt dann bauen wir im stream
ein bisschen zusammen
Windrigning
Ja aber wenigstens
Versuchen sie das nicht einem das leben schwer zu machen sondern lassen das einfach dran
Nicht so wie die china-chinesen steckdosen in letzter zeit wo du an nichts mehr dran kommst
Normalerweise leuchte das nur richtig richtig
Das video gucken wir uns dann an wenn wenn wir anfangen zu bauen davor
Normalerweise leuchte das nur das hat ein controller drauf
der nichts anderes macht als die led anzusteuern
Und mit diesem extra controller
Also mit einem esp 2 30 und esp 266 wenn man sich hier an den i-square-c bus dran stöpselt
Falls das einer ist
Kriegt man die daten direkt raus
Wenn ich gerade gejohnt was sehe ich hier das ist ein video wie einer sein ikea sensor umbaut
So das hatten wir i build a big rack server for my homelab weil er 15 minuten
Die weiß ist immer das gucke ich immer unglaublich gerne an solche videos
Einfach weil ich immer wissen will was die andere leute daheim haben
10 full stack apps
Fireship besser besser channel hier should you build your own router nee die antwort ist eigentlich relativ einfach nein
Es sei denn man hat ganz spezielle anforderungen zum beispiel irgendwie ein
Proxy
Mit login portal und und automatisch voucher generator oder sowas dann lasse ich mir vielleicht pf sense oder open sense oder sowas gefallen
Aber die allermeisten leute wisst ihr mal ehrlich mit was die allermeisten leute wirklich daheim am besten fahren
Das ist ihre stink normale fritzbox. Das ist easy zu benutzen das kann fast alles was man so braucht
Wenn halt auch das ding eigentlich kein ordentlicher router ist
Das ding eigentlich kein ordentlicher router ist
Und auch sowas wie vlan unterstützung schon nice wäre aber gut ist halt so
Ich finde es ja immerhin auch immer lustig dass die fritzbox als router verkauft werden muss ja sagen ich glaube so ziemlich das kleinste
Feature set hat die fritzbox beim thema
Router beziehungsweise ja als als eigentliches netzwerk gerät das ding hat keine vlan unterstützung das kann das ding kann keinerlei routing protokolle
das kann eigentlich so gut wie nix
Was ich von einem router erwarten würde aber man nennt es router was eigentlich witzig ist
Ja irgendwelche sachen gescheit blockieren kann es sein dass man es auch nicht so gut wie ein netzwerk gerät
Ja irgendwelche sachen gescheit blockieren kannst du auch nicht drauf also das ding ist ein wunderbares multifunktionsgerät wenn man
zum beispiel eine deckt basis station mit dabei haben möchte
Oder ein integriertes dsl modem haben will oder ein low low budget nas mit einem usb stick dran oder sowas
Da ist das alles ganz nice oder als tv server für
dvb t dvb dvb c
anschlüsse
Oder solche dinge dafür ist die fritzbox ganz nice aber im eigentlichen kern von netzwerk
Und router funktionalität ist die eigentlich ziemlich kacke aber trotzdem ist das für die meisten leute daheim
Das einfachste und beste gerät was alles in allem hat und wo 99 prozent der leute ohne probleme mit über die runden kommen
Und heute hat sie zwar aber ist das die x86 kiste die die mal gebaut haben
Mit diesem low power intel oder es ist ein anderer
Ach nee tatsächlich ja
Der ist wirklich ganz gut
Das ist wirklich ein cooles bord aber es gibt mittlerweile bessere boards es gibt nämlich mittlerweile boards mit
serienmäßig mehrfachen 2 2,5 g netzwerkkarten das finde ich tatsächlich in der heutigen zeit sinnvoller
Hast du im haus netzwerkkabel verlegt ja allerdings selber gemacht naja
Also die kabel
Also die kabel haben die leute die
Wände aufgemacht haben und und sowas haben die gleich mit durchgelegt also da habe ich nichts selbst gemacht
Was ich selbst gemacht habe ist hier ein bisschen ein bisschen im arbeitszimmer ich habe einen kabel kanal dran gemacht
Wobei das stimmt nicht ich habe den ich also die die befestigung habe ich nicht selbst dran gemacht aber ich habe einen kabel kanal drauf gemacht
und habe da kabel durchgelegt habe
Eine netzwerkdose
Zumindest selbst aufgelegt weil ich
Den
Telekom anschluss der aus dem keller gekommen ist abgemacht habe und
Da drüber einen ganz normalen rj 45 stecker also ich hatte noch adernpaare aber es war nicht genug
Da habe ich das was die benutzt haben für den telekom anschluss abgemacht und aufgelegt an das so eine normale keystone dose
Da sich jetzt noch ein netzwerkkabel in keller runter habe aber ansonsten habe ich da nicht so viel selbst gemacht also
Das ist mehr oder weniger alles von denen die auch das haus renoviert haben
passiert
Ja, und ich habe damals nicht richtig nachgedacht ich hätte mehr netzwerkkabel legen lassen sollen noch in
flur und
generell eigentlich hätte ich netzwerkkabel in jedes
In den raum legen lassen sollen aktuell habe ich netzwerkkabel nämlich nur
Im serverraum im also das ist so ein kleiner kleiner abstell kaputt hinter mir den habe ich aber extra für so was
eingebaut oder bauen lassen
in meinem arbeitszimmer im wohnzimmer drüben im wohnzimmer unten
im keller in der einen ecke aber nur netzwerkkabel
in meinem schlafzimmer
und
an der außenwand
Neben meinem schlafzimmer da ist zumindest die möglichkeit noch eins durchzuführen
Ja ich hätte zum beispiel gerne netzwerkkabel gehabt jetzt mittlerweile im flur
gerade für die excess points wenn richtig wäre das richtig gut gewesen
im flur
oben und unten hätte ich gerne eins gehabt
Ich hätte gern eins in den oben und unten in der abstellkammer gehabt
Und wenn ich schon dabei gewesen bin auch oben und unten im bad einfach weil es geht
In der küche hätte auch als hingedurft wäre auch praktisch gewesen
Und
Im keller im keller eigentlich vorn und hinten eins aber gut ja kann man jetzt nicht mehr ändern
Hast du schon was mit lede open wrt gemacht ja aber das ist ewig ewig lang her ich habe meinen uralt
war das tp link
Ne was war damals diese geräte die netgear ne netgear war das glaube ich
Es gab mal eine zeit lang so so die router serie oder die switch serie schlechthin die
Quasi super unterstützt würde von open wrt das war glaub netgear netgear oder tp link ich
Ich glaube netgear
Ich glaube netgear war es schon ewig her das ist über zehn jahre her
Habe ich das mal auch so was drauf geklatscht ja so ein bisschen rumspielen aber aktuell habe ich nichts im einsatz
Man könnte sie beispielsweise
Kann man nicht ich wollte gerade übrigens low
Effort wird es machen wollte sagen man könnte sie ja decknass switch router dsl mode im kombi
Kombi gerät nennen nee es ist ok dass man das router nennt das ist schön kurz und griffig und die meisten leute wissen was damit gemeint ist
Kann die fritzbox mittlerweile mehr als ich habe keine ahnung
link links ist nicht netgear und tp link leute ich habe es im kopf durcheinander gerade links ist
Aus irgendwelchen gründen habe ich tp link
Und netgear irgendwie zusammen gespielt links ist
Du hast recht ja
Links ist war das ja das war jetzt was ganz billiges das waren die zeiten als die
Geräte noch also switcher und router
einfach
Billige weisse plastikkisten waren mit ein paar lüft schlitzen neben dran
Multifunktions teilnehme endgerät oder das ist gut
Ja wie gesagt ich habe auch leider nicht überall dahin welche wo ich haben haben möchte zum beispiel hatte ich keins vom erdgeschoss in keller
Deswegen habe ich jetzt ja das netzwerkabel was liegt zwischen server und kabel
Und das ist ja auch nicht so einfach
Ich hatte ich keins vom erdgeschoss in keller deswegen habe ich jetzt ja das netzwerkabel was liegt zwischen serverraum und keller
das wurde
ursprünglich mal missbrauch dafür um darüber die telekom leitung zu führen also die zwei adern
von der telekom
Und nachdem ich ja wo davon habe und kein telekom anschluss mehr habe ich jetzt die telekom adern oben abgemacht
und
abgeschnitten und
Die verbleibenden sechs adern genommen
Und oben und unten ein ein keystone netzwerk
Clipsdingen drauf gemacht wie heißen diese dinge eigentlich
Keystone aj 45
Ja so was da so was habe ich da drauf gemacht
Gucken, ob es da gescheite bilder von gibt dass ihr auch wisst was ich meine
Wie wrt54g klingt klingt in die richtung irgendwie ja guckt genauso funktioniert das
Du stöpselst hier deine kabel rein klemmst das hier rein und dann musst du es einfach nur zu
zu klappen und durch das zu klappen schneiden sich hier die da sind kleine messer drinne oder kleine klingen drin die schneiden sich
Ins kabel rein dadurch dass das hier halt drauf drückt von oben wenn das zu machst und das das das
connectet sich quasi selbst
56k modem ja 56k modem ist richtig monka es
Hatte ich dachte du bist zu jung dafür für 56k modem?
Du bist auch bald 30 beats batman
Und 56k modem sound beste jawoll
Genau
Das war das war der sound der high-end technik damals ja
Fax hört sich anders an fax hört sich anders an fax fax hört sich tatsächlich anders an
Naja ok
Nicht ganz aber
Aber man hört den unterschied also wenn man das regelmäßig hört du hörst den unterschied ich habe sogar damals rausgehört
Am aufbau sound mit wie viel geschwindigkeit er singt
Also über call by call
Anbieter hat ein 56k modem sich nicht zwangsläufig immer mit 56k
gesüngt und ich habe damals beim aufbau
Gehört ob das ich mit 56k oder weniger singt
Also so oft habe ich verbindung aufgebaut über modem
Lahn neben Klo kann man immer brauchen ja man kann tatsächlich ein netzwerkabel im klo gebrauchen
Ich weiß jetzt spontan aber nicht für was
Für was könnte ich ein netzwerkabel im klo gebrauchen lasst mal überlegen also war sich aktuell im klo gebrauchen
Lasst mal überlegen also was ich aktuell im klo habe ist ich habe eine waage die ist bluetooth
Ich habe
Eine wlan steckdose
Mit zweimal usb
Da ist der heizlüfter dran und ich kann dort mein handy rein stöpseln morgens wenn ich auf dem klo wenn ich wenn ich im bad bin
Zum aufladen falls ich aufladen muss ich habe eine zweite wlan steckdose
Da steckt aktuell nur ein esp 32 drinne
Der in einer wasserdichten box ist und hinter dem klo hängt
Die müsste eigentlich wasserdicht sein aber ist wasserdicht die hängt hinterm klo
Damit man nicht rüber fällt und der macht
Bluetooth low energy empfang für die waage und sendet es per mqtt weiter
Und sammelt auch gleich die low energy bluetooth low energy sensoren von den
Ich habe so bodenfeuchtigkeits sensoren für für blumen und sowas noch im einsatz sammelt er auch ein
Und noch in der dritte funktion an die habe ich aber gerade vergessen
Der macht lampe der macht die aquara sensoren was machte denn noch der macht drei sachen
Keine ahnung fällt mir gerade nicht ein
Ja die drei sachen habe ich im bad
Smart mirror finde ich wahnsinnig overrated und unsinnig
Dafür habe ich mein tablet was ich mitnehmen brauche kein smart mirror
Mir fällt nichts mehr ein im bad also im bad wäre es cool netzwerkabel zu haben aber ich bräuchte nicht wirklich eins
Im bad wäre es cool netzwerkabel zu haben aber ich bräuchte nicht wirklich eins
Dns drm deck deckt
Sorry
deckt nicht deck deck nas switch dsl router modem
Ja das macht ja noch viel mehr dass die fritzbox hat ja noch home automation sachen mit drinne und sowas aber die abkürzung ist gut
Dns drm da denkt sich glaube ich jeder was anderes drunter da denkt man das ist ein dns der drm
schutz hat oder so
Ich habe übrigens
Chat ich habe und ich habe viel zu viel geld ausgegeben wieder das das letzte war ich euch noch zeige ich bin mal gespannt ob das
wirklich so gut ist wie die reviews sagen
Ja genau
Ich habe damals trick 17 gemacht also
Zu zeiten von modem hatte man ja nur eine leitung und wenn die voll war mit mit modem konnte man nicht mal telefonieren und wenn du
Das telefon abgehoben hast und wieder aufgelegt hast und du hast so viel du hast so viel krach am telefon gemacht
Dann ist ein modem abgekackt weil die jeden stelle gesagt hat das war aber kein modem sound also
Was ich damals gemacht habe es es gab schon schon damals gab es programme wo man übers internet mit telefonieren konnte
Also quasi so die vor vor vor vor gänger von discord oder skype
Und teams wie teams wie
Teams wie könnte es damals sogar schon gegeben haben doch teams wie gab es damals glaube ich schon aber das war wirklich so
wirklich richtig
richtig mies und damals konnte man aber auch schon nicht icq ja icq gab es auch nie es gab damals
Dienstleister die haben dich ins festnetz telefonieren lassen vom computer aus
Nee das hat gar nicht so viel gekostet das war ging über die internetleitung und da konntest du quasi telefonieren und nebenbei surfen
Weil du übers internet telefoniert hast aber leute das beides zusammen über
56k modem das war kein spaß
Aber aber ja die internet hat doppelt gekostet du musstest ja damals
Deinen internet provider bezahlen und du musstest telefonkosten bezahlen für die verbindung zu deinem internet provider
also wenn du beispielsweise was ich damals verwendet habe ist
MSN nicht msn msn call by call
War damals sehr angeguckt mal msn startet zweites internet by call angebot von 2002
easy server pro at msn also
1,35 cent die minute
Im minutentakt
Und
dazu muss
Und dazu musstest du natürlich die telefon gebühren zu dieser nummer bezahlen noch
also das war
Relativ teuer und ich habe es damals auch geschafft einmal
Ich glaube über 500 euro telefonrechnung zu bekommen das war
Ja war keiner so wirklich begeistert
Ja aber ich wollte euch auch sagen ich habe mir ich habe mir ein ich habe mir ein
ein swiss tools
Pb
9199 5 1 9 1 5 0
Ein swiss tool schrauben dreher set bestellt die dinger sind ab fuck teuer
Aber ich habe ein review video gesehen auf youtube die das ultra krass gelobt haben dass das quasi
Die mega nice sein soll
Und der scheiß ist wirklich teuer
Aber es sind halt schweizer da muss teuer in schweizer fragen ist es wahrscheinlich noch teurer
Das kommt wahrscheinlich auch morgen oder oder am montag
Bauform 24 ne die gucke ich aber auch gerne ne da war es nicht zwingend englischsprachiger channel
Und da bin ich mal gespannt ob das wirklich ob das wirklich taugt
Ja das schweizer fragen in euro eins zu eins in bringt ja nichts der kram ist halt einfach teurer dann alt in euro
So
Poe zahnbürste kennt ihr noch
Kennt ihr noch für das video
Ich habe doch mal ein video zu meiner zahnbürste gemacht
Wo ist das video zu meiner zahnbürste hin ist weg
Amazing dankeschön für den zapp
Gleich gleich ist betke angesagt
Keine ahnung was der hat
56k war das letzte was es gab ja
Ja ich glaube
Ich glaube ich glaube es gab 14,4 gab es glaube ich
9,6 14,4
33,6 und
Und 56k glaube ich ja
Die quick quickscope zahnbürste ja ich weiß was kenne ich wo ich mal wieder
Hier
Ups die pro gamer zahnbürste genau
Ich einfach zahnbürste damals
Das ist eines der unsinnigsten gadgets aller zeiten gewesen leute ich habe das nie verwendet
Die zahnbürste ist nicht schlecht
Aber der kram dabei habe ich nie richtig verwendet
Das hat ja sogar eine smartphone app die dir dann die zahnbürste verwendet hat
Das hat ja sogar eine smartphone app die dir dann anzeigt ob du lang genug an der richtigen stelle geputzt hast und sowas habe ich nie verwendet war mir zu aufwendig
So leute ich glaube es ist bettgeteim
So wo ist denn mein outro
Gibt es gibt es gibt es den soundtrack nicht mehr auf youtube
Doch alles klar leute wir sehen uns bis denn
Machts gut co
Ja
So